hey everybody welcome to Monday how's it
going welcome this week we have special
star Zoolander 2 Cyrus Arnold is here
thanks for coming Cyrus and as always
bet this over here in the chat room
Jason O'Malley in the corner let's see
they it's the cameras too far away today
we're gonna play a battleblock theater
so we can play with you if you want to
download the game we're playing on Steam
today but we're using these awesome Xbox
controllers that's right Xbox it's the
best Xbox yeah I know it kicks the kicks
the Jesus out of all the other exercises
so Cyrus and I are gonna choose our head
shape yeah and then we're gonna get into
it how would be so cool if you get to
design your own body I know it'd be
amazing I want to be like Tom Cruise I'd
have that kind of physique I think if I
could choose anything in my own body I
would have really long arms like super
long arms like to be able to like reach
the TV way over here in bed and then
like the alarm clocks all the way yeah
well I guess we couldn't find shirts
that would fit us yeah all right you
ready
is this good shape what shape could I be
you know is that even the shape I think
that looks like this like your head to
be like this I know you have like a can
like a cannon what's going on yes we
shall Amish good to see you hey can you
kill that chat replay thing atop there
oh yeah uh named Lincoln good see good
to see you good to see you
perfect all right you ready yeah all
right let's do it hit a hit when you're
ready oh there's no great green green
okay I just go colors cuz it's so hard
to figure out what okay I'm thinking no
one else is gonna choose this so I'm
gonna be unique be unique be yourself be
yourself
I love his face expression which is like
hey guys I'm a shape that doesn't exist
he's so bummed out he's like be wise
open eyes go see Zoolander 2 it's
awesome
oh thank you that's right that's right I
hit hit a hit agree agree agree and can
I choose my I don't know if you could
pick your well what you look like there
yeah
do I wear clothes yeah we do have
clothes on okay luckily it's not too
naked shapes running around
it's pg-13 I love what that guys doing
in the current he's just like [ __ ] maybe
they're dancing I'm like yeah I'm hip
exactly what I'm sad about it hey buddy
holla wani good to see you
Weezer what's up oh well that's got a
fan people sir some people are fans of
that oh really
right that's right that's pretty popular
on the old interwebs all right hey Green
hit Green okay Green Green Green Green
enjoyed shooting my own just we don't
have I didn't unlock I just started this
so there's no right all right here we go
oh my god this game is super awesome
super fun follow morghulis good to see
you alright let's go this way
so SOA jumps and X and X like does stuff
okay so I'll go to the right Oh what do
I go do I go on this cage thing here we
go
so there's not a cat cop I think we're
in this world where the cat's our new
cartoon cop coming this wall here hit
watch fights crying I just like my crime
by being it's like a police department
it's like you're a cat and you're good
at fighting people I'm tired I'm not
exactly sure what we're supposed to do
in this I don't like the Batcave
I know it's never been opened ever this
is here yet right oh I think this is the
first level is that in there I think
it's just I'm just it's a bunch of
people I think look watch it cats are
there many people inside stuff oh here
we go guys give me super weird it looks
like God it looks like Mario I know
oh yeah I got the gym yeah oh no oh no
oh me water
okay that's how you can Clemen the
blocks what is it-- sick teasing me wait
how do you tsunami I'm gonna go guitar
up there wait I don't know I don't know
it's like your tea stop me wait you
gotta come over
help me dude I'm gonna come over and
help me raise iris artsy just jump
okay we're hey I guess a lot of time you
jump I know it come back sorry about
stopping me you're hot
worse hours tomato hurry I won't okay
let me try to come back alright alright
just no wait no go are you telling us to
say RT RT right trigger alright so jump
up I'm gonna pull you up
jump up alright double jump we see how I
helped you there yeah teamwork teamwork
get up higher
I'm sorry I'm using this right oh good
what kind of person would design blocks
me now to log on it's like okay but you
wouldn't jump off long look at the
screen wait hold on come over here I'm
gonna throw you over this thing okay
here we go we can see that yeah that's
teamwork
yeah we're like the dynamic exit exit to
left what are we going to the left this
way this way down here oh my god this is
the best sunset nice job wait woody I
wish I could do that in real life just
go like we we did it we did it yeah
teamwork teamwork get into the goddess
sorry Dan the 40 can exit he looked like
he was getting killed when he jumped in
he's like no no don't what's like Bob
potage hello what's happening that's
right guys we just join us with service
Arnold from Zoolander 2
how how how is the movies probably
amazing all these awesome people what
was what was something that was what did
you learn from it what about that about
that did you paying attention you learn
oh I was but will ferrell
ya know it was so funny yeah I know
I can do what he does I am I got
inspired by him so I tried to go for my
pointy-head you can get up on the cloud
we yeah nice I was inspired by him so I
tried to improvise oh really hello and
then Ben Stiller's like behind the
camera gone like don't do that but yeah
so I already know feral does it
everyone's laughing you know and then
like I tried to do it and then I say
something really stupid and he's like
don't stop it's not talking know what
though I think but wills been doing it
for a long time that's how I get better
man yeah this is like my first yeah you
gotta you gotta fail you got to do it
and fail I now get better oh good you're
back on drowns in water so you don't
like when there's lava is like okay
maybe our heads don't really have you
know maybe our heads are super heavy
they oh my gosh you look like big old
heavy heads come on no you're right
especially here's like a mini pyramid
there's like uh like I don't think I can
make it through a doorway there you
there you go thank you I'm coming up I'm
coming over you are wait I'm not falling
for that again
well you have you can oh where am I
going I don't know why aren't you coming
oh sorry oh look you responded that's
right all right how do I get over where
you are oh he's right you just go to
that blimp
oh there we go now let me jump on this
cloud and leave you ha ha oh she there
you go that's right for being let go I'm
gonna get up on this cloud yeah you get
a gym you unnies am i you're gonna drown
but come over here and I can throw you
up wait hold on I'll throw you up oh I'm
sorry
wait what are you are we supposed to be
down here what's done are you trying to
chase me or what I've tried to be I'm
your teammate I'm trying to be teeny
okay TV I'm tell you is that a word
okay oh no no that's [ __ ] it should be
though right we just made like let's say
we created the words wait here we go the
avengers would say that's like
sometimes it's like Robert Downey jr.
yeah guys you're not being cheated or
salt Thor you have tied up yeah Beauty
me
more TV where do we go now those exit
open it says where's the exit it keeps
dangling it's like go you're never mind
go here Pookie man yes the behemoth it
makes the best games he's the Oh
darkness but what you have to get to buy
this cat guy oh what the heck is that
cat cop oh no he just shoved us shoved
me in the water I'm drowning why is he
so happy about that yeah I found you on
cool whoa exit number two baby
we're killing it right now you're
killing it
did you watch the Oscars last night yeah
what did you what did you think what is
it what what were some of your favorite
movies this past year oh well you know I
hear that side Zoolander - yeah okay
yeah did you see ya think okay Deadpool
is kind of Awesome oh dude I gotta see
you see that movie no do you are you
accomplished man yes I am
so many good people comment oh man -
temple is awesome I haven't seen it I
feel like they should use taskmaster
instead of Ajax Oh interesting
yeah because taskmasters like he's not a
mortal but he's kind of like the bizarro
Batman totally yeah he's a genius he's
kind of like look at that one direction
I could just jump on is he throwing like
hair balls what is he spinning I don't
know what that is I was like green
emerald Gumbo's but who's the guy who am
i thinking of who only thinking of who's
like tax master but he's got the orange
he's only got one eye the orange the
sword Oh on Deathstroke yeah yeah yeah
they should have a Deathstroke in there
was an awesome you should just do a
Deathstroke movie you know be sweet yeah
but then Deadpool would kind of see them
because that's like that joke is like
the more serious version of Deadpool
that's - why do you just me he's like
Deadpool without the jokes oh you know
what wait here's how we do it teamwork
pal I'm gonna stand here and you go
across you get the glory I'll stand here
you go down you go down to get it what
do I go you're up top go down together
think I'm gonna stand on these weird
blocks Oh
no wrong way wrong way where am I going
go down where I am there we go look I'll
stand here and you just run across oh
thank you
there we go do it you're probably gonna
commit suicide that's what it is that's
what it is wait how do I you gotta help
me out come over here let me repress
Ricky wait wait all right here I'm gonna
help you there we go
thanks bro hey anytime okay oh yeah look
at me I'm parkour this is kind of like
cartoon party ha
it's like animated parkour it's kind of
Awesome Adventure Time meets you know
Lethal Weapon that's just I love
adventure time by the way yeah oh my god
it's amazing I like a little song they
sing oh do Weezer says Deathstroke is DC
don't be MIT that's true Deadpool's
marvel yeah struck right they couldn't
do that yeah ah
Kozue 14 yes I have a pyramid head yes
gianmarco
Conan's at rehearsal right now alright
yeah it was amazing that pool is
incredible what's your favorite comic
book movie oh my god you know Deadpool
is up there now now that I saw it I
loved Avengers AI Avengers two Dark
Knight but it doesn't follow after the
comics it's like The Killing Joke
integrate CSI blended together yeah
exactly exactly that's true it's what
comics are you reading now Oh
after I saw the movie I'm reading way
more Deadpool is that true yeah that's
awesome I was reading a lot of Deadpool
now I'm reading even more you just up to
your eyeballs in Ted I know yeah
wait where do we go here um did you ever
go to comic-con oh yeah we actually we
did our show guy might know my dream is
to gonna come so fun yeah fun wait here
you know what come over dragon soon it
was the buzz it was especially cold you
do like the figures and stuff that you
collect us cuz they have a ton of stuff
there that sometimes you can only get at
comic-con which is really cool oh wow
that means I like comic-con wanna punch
you
we're teammates I really sorry alright
I guess you could change your head if
you oh look at this what you have a
beard you're gonna go over
real life this hive news for you one day
you me I don't know oh can you go down
and get a beer
oh yes you you can get it oh that's
pretty dope oh it looks like oh my god
they're all so happy about what they
look like
brain this guy's hippy this guy's is
like a peanut butter sculpture big hurry
here I bet he can hear real good
I know these are really good peanut
butters I'm an ocean shady-ass what
would you know what would you cosplay
for comic-con
what would you dress up a Deadpool would
you go oh um although the temples got
the masks could be hard to breathe in
that thing all the time you know it's
hot down there yeah but he's kind of
immortal so you can just go like yeah I
can suffocate that's true
it won't matter he regenerates yeah who
would you dress up as oh definitely
cuz Batman's so cool yeah he's the one
takes so much to go how did you how did
you just I don't know just press this
dude I love that pick a good color
that's okay I'm gonna be um I'm tired of
eating peanut butter sculptures blue
gonna be a blue okay that guy's that
this is pretty cool
I'm a fan I want to look like a
superhero see if you get that looks like
a wannabe superhero that looks like an
alter ego that looks like I got that
looks like that's the Bruce Wayne look
like an adorable mutated infant the
circular and no nose just like that's a
good costume are you a Halloween guy do
you like just following on you know just
to get this I usually hand out candy
today hey are you okay no candy I like
it yeah I uh
whatever has a character Oh whether it's
you know you go I usually when there's
you know little kids I usually dress up
as a superhero run out and then when I
see
bunch of teenagers coming by you know
running behind the bush you like to
tailor your costume oh yeah whoever's
coming up to the door I feel like
there's a bunch of little vending
machines in there yeah and then you it's
like a man yeah it is a man was great
that was a phenomenal that's what that
was how they pulled that off
I don't know man it was awesome I know
he's so funny I got him I like your
basket while I drown sorry you're back
you'll come back I don't know if you can
actually get mad at a bunch of cats wait
look at this hair bush I get this hair
ball thing what how do you support Wow I
think we got a here let's oh good
oh my god wait maybe if I get up here
you'll just appear I'm here with me III
like no I want to be a cat if I was an
animal just realize no just because you
can do anything you can be a jerk and
then everyone's like oh how cute that's
true they still love he's punching the
baby oh oh he's eating the baby that's
so know what a dog does they're like hey
fluffy how dare you what a cat does it
oh thanks for letting you up there you
do cats cats weirdly get it - I know
it's like that's not fair just because I
have a bunch of wish goes all over my
nose I'd also like they're real soft I
think that's why - like that's why cats
why are those family things up there
with a yarn tied to it
I think those are I think those are
prizes we've got feel like they're
trying to tease us like yarn come give
the yarn no you can't I don't know you I
think know I like sloths
do you like slaw yeah like I'm a feel
like they got the claws they move real
slow
yeah there's just like so adorable I
like a guy I like a nice slaw
although I think maybe you would get
kind of get frustrating being a slaw my
pets are not allowed for you to own and
you would like to own mmm that's a good
question monkey a monkey a monkey is I
put a little tuxedo why cuz you could
dress him up looking a little bit Seto
he would definitely rip my face off but
you know that's kind of it's fun you
know it's Dean it's fun to have your
face being ripped out it's fun to have
the danger like you never know what's
gonna oh yeah it's life it's like a
adrenaline yeah the adrenaline of just
like
you gonna rip my face off or am I gonna
live another day yeah but monkeys
monkeys are actually pretty smart so
water act like fool against I don't know
cuz they can like an old man age we
didn't have monkeys at rip your face off
I know hey we gotta get him I think we
need another green jewel Oh Brendan says
I would want a panda that's interesting
why upon a pandas a bear and bears or
scary bear the viewer just me like leave
me alone
bears would rip your face off bears are
very no but pandas are kind of nice
about it you know I dude I don't think
so if they want to rip your face off
pandas do it in a really kind way I'm
really Kyle just kindly rip your face
I'll just cut I'll just slowly right
like I'll kill your face I'm trying to
make it as less painful as possible
that's so nice of you Panda I know I
know
yeah it's like when you start to scream
they're just like no don't worry you
want a slower okay oh dude
speaking of skulls I was obsessed with
Ghost Rider for a long time used to be
my favorite okay I I like the movie yeah
sorta yeah it was fun okay oh I didn't
like it but the times when the skeleton
appeared on screen there we go
when he jumped off the building oh my
god Shane and just do it amazing
striving down the checklist case I agree
man I agree but uh but yeah I was
obsessed with Ghost Rider forever
yeah shoe what's cooler than a skeleton
driving better Ghost Rider movie yeah
you know what it wasn't scary it wasn't
scary
yeah like ah yeah but I think they could
make one that would be super creepy but
you know her she bleed III love the
villain cuz he overacted yeah jess is
just so cool it was like a Heath Ledger
meets yeah Red Skull Hugo Weaving
totally totally I think that they can
Agent Smith me yet it's like a gothic
speaker by the way agent listen dr.
Starnes mater God gothic Darth Vader
that's a movie right there
yeah oh man how do we get that green gem
up there though
wait hope you know I'm gonna throw you
over that Gloria oh thanks thanks look
the rock throwing me part of the game
wait
Ursula why don't you love that little
move though huh that's wrap that
complaining now
Darby so cool what if in the boss level
in this game that it would just mean
slow motion I hope there is no flipped
over and follow me oh dude it'd be like
some kind of cult got some kung fu stuff
right there
now what's your opinion foo movies your
fan or not a family oh yeah um I'm
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon is amazing
amazing they just didn't they just do
some gotta see yeah sort of destiny have
you seen it it's on Netflix have you
seen it Netflix and chill alive yuichi
really yeah you got to man that's life
wait here let me put your Netflix thing
oh that's a good question
no I have you seen daredevil Oh Ben
Affleck no I know yeah he's a guy here
supposed to be amazing
yeah watch it you're adding they're
adding the Punisher next season punch oh
the guy from walking down watch it got
to me yeah if I get permission you know
like [ __ ] you remember Shane do you ever
watch Walking Dead Shane from Walking
Dead's good he was I hear yeah yeah I
think so
oh wait either honey I don't watch
Walking Dead it's either right or the
actor it's either him or the guy who
played god that's amazing I'm just gonna
do the whole game now good oh I like the
slime I gotta say what is that is ah ice
cream dude what's up with this get away
from me bro no you just let your loving
that [ __ ] do you think of an Police
Department nickname a Police Department
nickname yeah
you mean like I don't know what's it
like like who was the guy in ycd if this
was taking place in New York oh there we
go
NY NY seedy New York cat department dude
just killing it killing it
well better call Saul you ever see
better call Saul that's a pretty good
show Oh
that's the spin-off of Breaking Bad yeah
yeah yeah awesome yeah oh yes wait
people you're on Instagram right it's a
turtle that's awesome are you a Twitter
or anything else I'm on Twitter and and
Facebook and your honor
yeah you gotta be except for my space
yeah forget my space
although dude maybe we bring it back we
bring it yeah we make my space yeah
maybe we bring it back I think it's time
we rename it well it's kinda weird
naming in my space I know it's kind of
like it's like get away but follow me
it's a little creepy I know it's like
you know my space come over here
why am I always talking about he
pleasure right I don't you're obsessive
he would I mean he's awesome Joe he's
incredible no he's with Joker better
died for a performance too with Joker
did you like I gotta say man top bait
I'm a big fan of Tom Hardy baby
that was incredible did you just see me
that's all the you know yeah we're
thingies were disappearing I'm running
yo but do it in real life though yeah
I've got them there you'll get up there
I got them Jukes got the juice
oh no I failed what's the Co
exactly watch me do the Jukes wait here
get up here I'll throw you get up go
start out oh you almost made it
sorry dude exactly hold on one sec I got
you not a service know about MySpace
dude who doesn't know about MySpace what
are you talking about yeah exactly
you know everyone goes on MySpace now
yeah dude that's the new place what like
everybody goes on Instagram I bet you my
buddy uses Instagram now ten bucks says
myspace is gonna come back in the next
three years really yeah don't you think
it could maybe I don't know as a joke is
a joke
let's get on boys like yeah brother our
website we use in like 2005 well we're
bringing it back he'll not get here long
for you oh god I keep dying
dude are you right honey you know
drowning like there's this y'all gonna
pick me up strike you're gonna wear this
tall and the water is this and we're
drowning that's not
every time you get in the water it's
like oh no I know it's like a horror
movie cliche oh dude you like horror
movies oh yeah which one's your favorite
uh I just saw it follows not too long is
it good it's it's really scary but it's
not like gory or anything it's just
really creepy
yeah it's about this thing it's like
about it's basically you get cursed look
at a scariest one you've ever seen Oh
shining oh my god that imagery Sonny you
know I get creeped out
I get creeped out by stuff that's like
oh thanks all right stamp their stamp
there wait okay come to the edge come to
the edge and hold are gonna help you
here hold the right trigger yes yeah so
your body is really cool yeah oh you
know what here I wish I could climb like
that what do you mean dude doing it
dance because we shot you're not allowed
to learn parkour and then because that
that's as close as we could become the
human can oh wait them over here yeah
parkour is yo thank you I hear wait get
over here my throw you over i'ma throw
you over wait no nope yeah yes all right
now you would just do oh no here we go
okay here we go no I'm not cool we're
figuring it out see you're helping out
your teammate who cavenda would you just
leave it there he's just gonna cross his
arms like yeah I just helped you
chilling just like a badass
you see cabin in the woods no I heard
that celebrate it's more of a
celebration of yeah it is it is but it's
still real it's really fun Josh Sweden
amazing do you watch Buffy the Vampire
Slayer I've seen a couple of us since I
haven't seen them I've seen the whole
show really yeah huge fan
yeah I've seen all seven seasons do I
need to start at Season one or can I can
I have to start the whole thing it's
kind of a season mark like you're the
same characters every season but it's a
new enemy everything well that's kind of
cool there's so there's like a a big bad
guy every yeah that they fight yes it's
weird cousin most of the show there's
only one season where the villains
actually uh two seasons where the
villains actually uh you know vampire
yeah and then the rest of it shows these
demons yeah that's like Buffy the demons
no it's actually about me the road right
she only kills one okay now just kill
viruses like kitten Connor it's just
deeds but why do they call the vampires
like we do their got a dog I had a dog
called Buffy and he was like a low Buffy
the Slayer of Hell spin-off a remake I'm
kind of surprised at the third time they
brought expose back I'm surprised they
haven't brought Buffy no it's like a
continuation there actually if you look
on IMDB yeah the new show is actually
season 10 of the old show really yeah I
was an error mind-blowing but yeah it's
weird
did you like it did you like that I
thought it was okay there's there's some
parts of it I really liked get up there
get up get our coat okay
I already did this way did you watch
American Horror Story
I don't is it good really loud I don't
know no but every everyone is told me
yeah it's like hey you watch them you
watch this show I don't scare easily it
made you angry yeah well that's why I
didn't want to bring it up but they did
kill my whole family oh it's okay
that wasn't very sincere apology by the
way you're like I'm sorry I was like a
courtesy you felt like joked about your
family I'm sorry you you had a hand in
their death
I know exactly yeah I could see I could
tell you I was like easy cheesy 80s
cheesy villain like they have a gun up
to their head it's like dude why are you
gonna kill me I'm so sorry you cut two
knots
hashtag nut sounds like something gentle
would say it does Thanks well chasing it
I'm here he's freaked me out I'm not
gonna lie to you white thing Winky thing
are you scared of bugs Eliquis bugs
freaked me out
no but all vultures and birds do really
yeah
why are you scared of vulture no I'm not
scared of my dead body
no they only know things I bet someone's
gonna leave
comment just posting up a vulture yeah
wait why I'm gonna change my profile to
a full justice scare you
why do you fold your scare you of all
the bird no it's just I think in the zoo
one day one like looked at me like why
would you pull up a that just etiquette
what if I told you about vulture no
you're mean you're mean
dude vultures are free Frankie now that
I'm seeing worst host ever yeah they are
you know I gotta like scare your one
guests on the show they got like weird
like like skinned heads like we're like
yeah that scares me don't do it you're
making me die we're a team bet they're
bringing down the team
if you're vulture time I'm kind of
surprised I mean you are that that
woulda music yes staring teens you know
scaring people so much younger than me
is so funny yeah I hope you're however
teenager did you just you know show
babies The Shining she probably did
actually shining she probably did I mean
Jack Nicholson's Jack Nicholson that's
you master but also I should have never
told you I really regret that if you
show weakness or I'll bet she pounces
open up a new tab and go like
[Music]
exactly that's your fear okay she look
at me bro I will be reaching down
reaching down for ya I'm gonna throw you
up throw yeah there you go
suddenly you know your Hamlet you're
looking for something how do we get up
there how do we get this Mike come here
yeah yeah come here be some money [ __ ]
you Sonya you hired hurry some money
will help to help you out I'm dead just
died here we go
how do we died these guys there's a lot
of things where are we now that we just
get killed who's building these levels
that are okay it's weird how bad my
walks wouldn't kill you it helps you
boost up yeah Oh like two feet of water
inches of water this much water kills us
but burning magma we're fine with wait
hold on I'll throw you over there again
there we go ready go have you ever Conan
O'Brien on the show yeah really
that's right absolutely yeah cuz people
are asking where's Conan I know well
he's shooting something now but yeah
comes in every so often wait can you
wait post put the drill in through that
boot Oh throw that you're never gonna
make it without me bro we're a team true
we're a team
sorry that's all you try yeah I try to
go supposed to do with this I'll try
pushing it from the son of model yours
hanging out in your yard
yeah that's right why are you facing the
other way I don't I'm angry you should
be like dude
well you're sky waiting for you to push
the boat out what how do I do I jump out
of the boat I am i hiding in the boat
there's nothing I know you can probably
a vulture nearby you're scared before
you are see on my picture of the wall
you've scarred Cyrus for life I know
alright sit there give me that boat
little watch you open up a tab
please don't why did you fall oh man
wait hold on I'm gonna get this boat to
you here we go let's jump up yeah yeah
no oh no you're pretty it's a thing
really we gotta get back in the boat
back in the boats have you ever been a
mind of its own no I'm controlling the
boat alright here we go ready I go I'm
sorry I didn't mean to show me ok now go
on alright no I'll just wait
yep there we go have you ever been
sailing you're gonna know you ever go
sailing you go cross-eyed zero across
you go across look at that teamwork look
at this dude try to overwater me no
hacks Taggart oh I did I killed him he
deserved it he did say he didn't do
anything saying bad things about you I
didn't want it oh yeah he was used
gossip there anytime anytime
I gotta kind of stick out for my breath
is that a machine gun
whenever it closes I don't know look at
many other like yeah I'm gonna shoot the
ceiling merely stating why is that guy
crying stings like a good job right now
I'm supposed to have my thumb she hates
to see us you see he hates to see us
succeed how do we spinning out
boomerangs that's physically impossible
for cats whoa oh nice job I didn't even
see these over happy you cat do these
cats are really getting on my nerves I
like it over here come here
I like Merrick I'm gonna shove you now I
like it off oh thanks you're welcome
wait don't sail away without me okay
how do I get down there no chump chump
can I go down this where the cat
swallows a bloomerang again I don't know
if I could get down there you might have
to just go without rose oh here we go
here we go here we go
boom let's go yeah that's really super
fast boat well the face of the buoy
levitates the air definitely tomorrow
it's definitely gonna leave a mark
I know yeah do you know what's got hit
in the face remember I need some water
Wow what no I'm not good at vines I need
I need a little more than what is it
three seconds you just need to come on
you know I'm a bit slow yeah I can do a
live vine like here's a lot vine well
it's like
jadi yo what's up yo what's up yo what
here my live vine yo what's up yo what's
up I could see it so it's a latte
someone get a large if and then just
making it 15 minutes like can you
withstand how long can you dowon can you
do is stay in this vine the hour of the
vine dude sounds like Arnold
Schwarzenegger - can they are short
everybody go oh right okay Terminator 2
ot2 not predator what's crazy
hey Jay to the choppa dude greatest line
ever get you the chopped up to the job
angry it's having anything this lahat I
got yo oh my god this little haddock oh
dude we gotta get this golden boot
Schwarzenegger nothing just says
anything to him and then he
automatically gets angry like they get
to the choppa line he's like catching a
chopper he's like me when you asked
about American Horror Story no no I
don't know that's my Arnold I don't know
I know exactly it's like someone asked
you over and over hello from Spain
German say hello Spain what's happening
Oh commando what about commando that's
pretty cool you ever seen commando he's
carrying like the kind of silly though
yeah that's pretty dumb baby well jingle
all the ways a fun one
oh yeah money we're forgetting like
kindergarten cop killer run cop it's not
as you know they're making a new one
with the what why are they re making all
these great movie dude kiddo a cop is
perfect it does need to be remade thank
you very much I know yeah pitch that to
a studio yeah it's like we're making a
movie Arnold Schwarzenegger is a cop
Oh this drug deal yes by one like a six
like a six year old kid that's true it's
insane craziest picture and then it's so
funny it's like well done yeah well I
know it actually that's the thing it's
like they pulled it off I would imagine
like Leonardo DiCaprio at the Oscars and
the award goes to for best special
effects III cheered my head off when
Leonardo DiCaprio I know he was like
you deserved it I agree like he's
Leonardo DiCaprio
yeah he's baby needed that awesome
needed it he said he does watch the
Oscars right yeah I love you they held
it
okay I'm sorry if I spoiled if I stumble
yeah hashtag spoiler alert are you doing
I know I'm just reaching out your hand
well I'll try to throw you over there
you made me kill what you spit out the
wrong way I was sure I was so
embarrassed I was like I love a shame oh
dude we forgot about of noise we forgot
about our minds sorry now that was a
that was unnecessary oh my god
yo dude that's gruffy are we gonna
battle each other that's I just saw a
bone come out of his Anatomy yeah I
needed that phone horrible I needed that
bone in my in my body
I don't need it spread around should we
try to bail we're gonna stand the
comments that I'm spitting everywhere I
say my Peas right please can I have that
water wait should we battle each other
we moves you try to battle people online
you want to try to do it we could be a
team again you want to try yeah wanna
try let's do it we only have we only
have 15 minutes what's your nickname go
by I blame my nicknames play I'm coming
play do you have a nickname sighs I guy
sag I really my dad calls me when I was
like three dude that's rad I wish I only
got bleh later life
let me sigh like my friends at school
that's pretty cool yeah
sizing size of great Nicki I'm watching
all the comments right now you have to
they're great you have to love everybody
Blair that's right yeah if you're just
joining us by the way Sarah sorrow from
Zoolander - thanks go see it it's
amazing you follow my Instagram
Cyrus Arnold Facebook Twitter what else
you got Friendster MySpace no hold on
let's see you metal though is you melted
thing everybody like you mad bro is that
we mean I don't know what that is is
that like a website or something
you mad hahaha just blew up with a giant
fart what okay watch on this thing now
let's try to see if we can all right
here we go all right let's see we go to
online play online play player we are
people actually gonna from the comments
just gonna I think so I think I've never
done this before so we'll see how it
goes
player we're gonna host a player match
new arena what should we do should we
just beat up the enemy team what do you
want to do we can get me and get more
gold we could do a game where you throw
like it's like basketball do we were
doing before all right let's go back
yeah let's go back let's go back it's
not like The Cat in the Hat like look at
him I think it's like the guy in the top
I think it's like a wood like a creepy
cat looks like dr. Seuss I'm gonna
change myself I'm changing it up too
I'm tired little hips I think people
have been talking smack about my pyramid
head I don't like it I'm changing my
pyramid people are no I'm just okay I
think people make cat I'm like a cat the
kitten cops in the game I think I've
been like laughing behind yeah I could
see it we passed by oh I used to be a
little obscure no well you know what we
can change our thing okay no change it
back to peanut butter thing yeah there
now you want the peanut butter no we
could go peanut butter no I'm not kind
of guy that's like wicked wicked why
make it do peanut butter and then like I
mean my friends having an argument
uh-huh and then the girls like that
doesn't make sense I'm like yeah that
doesn't make sense
my friends like yeah it doesn't nothing
go to the rule I'm like yeah guys you
play it all the side oh yeah you're
playing on the pick a side I'm like I'm
sorry you're just picking all the angles
you're everybody's friend that's all
right so yeah shame hey that's a good
thing that's a good thing oh my god that
monkey species like dude go with the
monkey you know you want oh okay such a
cute little monkey yeah but do you think
butter knows peanut butter monk Henry
like have you guys ever seen the cabbie
a hat or how the Grinch Stole Christmas
yes yes he doesn't have a nose but you
don't want a lot of monkey monkeys all
creepy yeah like the Woo's look scarier
than the gritch himself I agree I agree
there horrifying she
I can't believe that's like a children's
book like these are like really scary it
shouldn't be oh wait wait what you think
I'm sorry I hate you now it looks like
the happy star scary laugh I love it
my gamertag's Blair alright here we go
now who should I be I don't know will be
mr. milk can hell yeah okay are you a
can head or a can't hear ya I'm a can't
both loom okay here we go
what wait how'd that go black wait I
think you did I think you might hit the
wrong button we'll go back and adjust a
disturbing way to introduc wait you're
not in it we got to go back you're not
in attack oh you're not in it go back
the SS friendship boat this was pulled
the SS friendship yeah that's what it
said like son of a gun
wait you know what maybe we've done
pretty well yes for a first-person
shooter
shady fridge I love that shiver so
shooters name is shady free today we're
gonna try and see me
you're like a sarcastic cheerio yo
what's up my name is Shane assure you I
know Jeff do Dick Cheney
what's the most 80s nickname you can
come up with please DJ Homeslice no DJ
MC taco bar you know like it where you
make your own what's in a teaspoon
what's an 80s food who likes slim jims
Slim Jim
yeah but you hit the wrong button I'm
sorry dude it's rum ah with you like
slim jims like beef jerky like that's a
pretty okay
macho man dude much of it had that oh
really yeah are you a wrestling guy at
all do you like wrestling you don't like
some juice they're delicious
I know they're gross I feel gross after
I eat it but they're fun to eat it's
like I'm like eating am i eating you
anyway the rash on your chest
yeah oh I've got a lot of rashes I know
Slim Jim rash what happened your stomach
Oh worth it because they taste good
it's worth getting physically hurt we're
gonna try insane mode we were doing
pretty well so I think we're ready for
insane mode I don't even notice it
alright piggy got hit and scared go
green go green go green oh girl oh go
green go green or go home here we go
great
green green wait wait hit green okay
green oh okay I'm gonna go green butter
your own peanut butter alright here we
go here we go finally finally we do
we're skipping the one oh yeah we don't
want to think about this movie I'm just
stirred by guys boys
ladies gentlemen it sounds like you
taste good we're on the friendship we're
on the friendship the friendship here we
go come on down I get it
play on words yeah well played game well
played you know I love it
Oh [ __ ] insane mode is no checkpoints
interesting all right here we go
the guys writing the comments so time to
Hulk out nice we're gonna hold like if
you read our YouTube videos people angry
what's your opinion on politics and
thirteen-year-olds I'm like I don't know
yeah we're playing stuff where she got
cute cubes and cans for heads and
they're asking but I'm actually not
first in court I don't know what I am
anymore
I believe in video games man where are
we where I don't know we're outside of
some like Gotham City it must smell
terrible out you know what rule thing do
like I'm gonna eat you it's like yeah
let's go in here that's a good idea
this guy shows like the DP is this
something the guy from South Park like
yeah it's like it's like a movie you
guys watch South Park right oh yeah
thank you
someone's that insanely racist inside
the peanut butter thing about I don't
know how that's racist I don't know what
you're talking about if they look like
they're made out of peanut butter
Hitler YouTube for it I would go go this
way into the door go hey let's go eat
hey Laurie YouTube
really serious why are people joking
about like Jewish yeah bro why do people
got killed this is bad yeah he killed
about a billion people just because they
were Jewish it's like yeah it was funny
we go to the right go to the right I
here's the problem now I know we don't
have noses in this game but I feel like
all with all this rain we might catch
some time it's weird cuz my dad's site
is Jewish oh my mom's side is you know
they celebrate Christmas that's awesome
when you get the best of both worlds
yeah about Hitler my grandpa like his
face gets all red yeah getting the eye
rightfully so looks like you just about
to rip your head off rightfully so you
do you blame them when people shouldn't
joke about the weight do you get would
you celebrate by Hanukkah and Christmas
then umm do you get maximum presence oh
no sometimes like if I'd you know
Hanukkah present yeah
I would you like a really lame Christmas
present Monica I get a guitar yeah my
family soup my feeling is super easy
just cats oh babe I don't know dude I
feel huge I think it's like radiation or
yeah see I think it's like okay their
heads have been like okay now it's going
the realistic turn wait oh this is the
guy who's crying dude why is he clothes
are big Ian yeah they're making him evil
he doesn't wanna ha he's crying because
he says this is like a politics they're
asking about guys want you track on
Titan oh my god oh yeah Netflix no I
don't want to talk I say we what is
attack on Titan
okay it's like there's this village it's
insane but it's incredible is in the
future no no no no it's kind of
mythological but not really okay
it's a bunch of giant love that attack a
village and this guy stands up to the
giant dude is it a movie er sure it's a
show and then they actually made a movie
about it in Japan whoa that's why I like
Dragon Ball Z a lot okay I can name like
ten
thousand enemies right now okay enough
let's do it so here's what I recommend
doing but do it in the order less
resistant I should walk okay
Hunter x Hunter mm-hmm blue exorcist
blue exorcist lack baller okay um wait
what no don't light you racist comments
it's about a demon Butler trying to
persuade a child into murdering people
oh yeah what's that called again
um Black Butler don't a racist life yeah
yeah people are they sang a demon hell
was on the moon what is that it's like
crazy okay whatever dude a demon
Butler's insane wait wait I've got it
this is it the butler did the family
hire a butler and then later it turns
out he's a demon no I know he was a
demon who could see demons I was kinda
like either six like you know okay like
he follows him around and then he's like
here I've this axe I'm like wait wait so
oh wait so only the kid he's the only
person change all right get in my case
no wait is the kid the only one who can
see the demon Butler no it's like okay
it's weird isn't it
does it take place in this dimension is
it like oh no it's an alternate universe
Otacon demons exists got it but this kid
can see this one demon and then it's
what's the demons name it's like an
imaginary friend is it like surreal
is it like he'll even have like a normal
name oh I'm Phil the demon Cod a the egg
not a the egg Nate da mathe is my
buckler why are you writing
that's it's a quarry in the house Oh
ninja wait ninja scroll hey can you move
the chat over so I can see the thing
burski says old-school Ninja Scroll
never watch Ninja Scroll it's a really
bad word someone really yeah that's true
the internet is full of terrible people
wait so what else so what you just
straight up one like yeah yeah cuz you
don't like us or Terrell yeah no no the
people who like drop one second and dude
you didn't get in the cage this time you
did follow your own advice
you're too busy talking about in the
cage you're talking about
even Butler which blew it so it's blue
exorcist
okay blue I don't know I just hear about
I do Netflix
I do a Netflix thank you wait don't go
all karma on me right here do you also
do and what is your opinion now like
unlike like the Amazon and people know a
black butler is yeah absolutely
people say that black Butler looks like
you Chewbacca's dad haha
Phil the demons he's a cool cat thanks
Jungle Jim mania thing is like if demons
were named with normal names like Phil
and Bob the G way less scary we are
terrible people baby yes thanks for
insulting King corn dude you got caged
you really hurt us feeling you got cage
now what are we gonna do I changed it
cage cage
that's right dude Nicky do Nic Cage what
are we doing
oh god no dude what are we - you've
forgotten all the lessons of being a
teammate look I'm down here look mine
just cuz I have a cube head it doesn't
mean you can just ignore me here there
you have to look at look how female you
see I like you ups even you make power
teammate Power Team a power now I'm
keeping you down though no stop it
I'm keeping it stop it I'm keeping you
down you can't keep it up I'm not in my
cage
it is my cage that's the worst I'm the
worst person how did you know how do you
find out oh we were I gotta throw you
over look cool as Madonna look cool -
people did that in movies what's your
go-to dance man like if it's like CSI
it's like wait before you kill me dude
wait would you call the show called
dance cops you know knows a way maybe
it's talking to mother nature like give
us a request like way before you make us
Oh Jim do you are you a dancer you get
out on the dance floor busted up do you
dance with Sam
no I'm yes so am I do but I still get
out there
I ain't daughter now even though it
keeps me alive it keeps you it's good to
drive one Scene one I love her this is
like a movie I know it's like a play you
sure make a movie Hollywood Hollywood
pay a - yes yeah dude Hollywood needs
and you're just gonna leave me over here
everytime haha unbelievable with a
Boondock sir you're a good guy okay fine
I never saw Joe I noticed on Dragon Ball
super make a mouse game make a mouse gun
do you even Dragon Ball I Dragon Ball Z
not good tracking ball I got you boy
dude thank you I got you boy oh you oh
sorry I slept right on your can't hit no
it's okay it's just easy to stand on
your head if you know all right Artie
for you over no no I'm gonna throw your
yeah whoo somebody said Super Mario
Brothers best 90 flick every cinema no
oh what the uh Ossabaw boskie boskie
yeah Malian accent you'll never see that
everything not because he's dead don't
be all hated on me
why because immediately go because if
you look at any of his work he'll never
do on Italian accent like he did that's
sure you're right he peaked as Mario
yeah one don't make me you know lose
gravity and die jungle-gym mania says
the characters remind me of Castle
Crashers it's by the same company yeah
by the same company that's why shut up
dude yo sorry sorry I'm sorry
oh my god guys were almost finished we
have five more minutes to Sarah Sarah
you guys got questions that's it man
time flies you're having fun oh thank
you staying on that fixed Anna no okay
no I'm skip
yeah favorite class I'm trying to think
what about I'll hit you with some
classes and you say you rate them on a
scale of one to five five being the best
of science okay um that's one of my
favorite so far
history okay I love that but the
teachers not so great
ah math I mean Matt you fainted Matt um
yeah yeah I feel really good right in
there that's it oh man dude I'm terrible
man really I'm absolutely the worst we
have to beat this game before time
yep oh no oh no dude I'm not gonna be
able to make it over there Oh over there
they depend on me now I can't
yo that was awesome well corfu says
funny video again factoid I did junior
studs for the Double Dragon movie oh
there we go that's it Oh sir yes sirs
just earned 50 points of Awesomeness for
like in science bro thank you okay yeah
I love space stuff do you like I like I
love like a strong skins did star in the
movie he was and others yeah I think I
love science in history there yeah I
like history exactly yeah I'm a fan of
history who favorite leave actually I'm
trying to think
be wise organized favorite Leo DiCaprio
movie favorite lady DiCaprio movie
Inception oh really
rabbit was awesome but yeah inception
was amazing do you think what's your
opinion at the end do you think he's
still in a dream or not we never saw
that never stop good that dialogue would
never happen not even a question you're
like my god high school play
did you go to the bathroom yes I did go
to the bathroom no no it's not really
yeah it's definitely a dream of dude I
can't get up there though you're my
drama
you're gonna die uh juggle Jemaine is a
great start to my week awesome dude I
think that's it man I think time's up
Syrus like pulp fiction I never saw it
uh it's pretty violent it's pretty
violent but good but good I don't know
what scene where John Travolta shoots
him in the face Jackson's like what you
do that and then judge involes is like I
don't know and then Jim Jackson's like
no yeah what Oh like I love like he only
cares about the fact he's ruined his car
yeah that's the bus um guys thank you so
much for joining us thank you Cyrus
so everybody follow him twitter facebook
Instagram hat Cyrus are soon coming to
myspace and go see Zoolander 2 which is
out now thank you all for joining for
Beth just know Valley do enter - uh it
gets you seal of approval
Oh like it well I should enhance with my
own
so yeah bro you're such a problem but it
was pretty dope
we're also people are gonna be in the
comments like there's so arrogant Cyrus
no wait what'd you say was that funny
and then if I say I don't like it yeah I
do like it yeah yeah exactly I don't
like it they're gonna be like sirs just
so mean you should you shouldn't be so
critical god no you can't win either way
the part that's Hollywood you can't win
either way that's why we play video
games video games don't you do someone
send me and stars go way back there we
go
well there we go way way back who is
that no one knows texting texting pronto
sending the vulture somebody oh thank
you guys enjoying it thank you - Cyrus
Arnold we'll see you guys on next week
thank you
you